[music]
I should at least write it,
I was sleeping
abruptly, an explosion occurred and I was thrown out at a
distance of about three meters from the room into the
corridor,
well, all the windows fell down, some sounds
on the street, I was afraid at first of the priests to
climb the subway on all fours, so to speak, I do
n’t at all  I understood this blow, I didn’t understand at all
what happened to me, because it was
as if someone took me and threw
me out, and then I already heard screams around the neighborhood, sounds
rose, all broken glass, all
beaten, everything beaten, started walking around the apartment,
quickly collected things, documents
that  in the evening I cooked and jumped out
into the street while I was gone for
two or three
hours.  ]
I will be Ukraine